le docteur jobson est demandée d'urgence
ou la cheerleader service cette année on
est anthony 20 heures vous êtes resté
dans le coma pendant presque vingt ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on m'a pas fait un genre de freaky
friday dans le corps d'une vieille rider
abois
pourquoi est-ce que tu habites ici avec
blaise push aller partent et la maison
de mes rêves à blaye mémoire nous
parents nous ont offerte en guise de
cadeau de mariage atterri pour ouvrir un
nouveau chapitre de ma vie je peux pas
rester coincé dans le précédent pendant
encore 20 ans j'ai l'impression d'avoir
quitté le lycée hier l'actuel super
panique
vous êtes à côté de la plaque mathé
inité
t'en a pas marre de chercher constamment
ce que tout le monde penserait reine du
bal c'est que nos efforts ont payé
[Applaudissements]
les portables et les nouveaux tamagoshi
genou a besoin
[Musique]